[Music]
all right
1572 we're playing some serious
opponents
guess what opening i'm gonna play the
king's
indian we had some requests i'm gonna
play the king's indian which is an
opening where you fee encounter your
bishop as early as possible
now in the well in the king's indian
as i've explained previously it's what's
called a hyper modern opening and in the
hyper modern openings
you give up a large share of the center
and in return you try to attack the
center from a distance
with some of your pieces in particular
the bishop the knight comes out
and you only claim control of the center
when you're ready to do so
this is the concept that people don't
always understand because it's not
intuitive to not control the center
your your conditions so early in your
chest career to control the center it
looks like white is winning here i mean
look at this
oh we've got nothing the reality is
black is already better he's
overextended himself
this is the essence of hyper-modern
openings when we strike in the center
we mean business the reason we mean
business is because the reality is my
pieces are positioned a lot better
than my opponents his bishop and his
knight aren't really coordinated
and he's basically going full steam
ahead engaging me in the center but he's
not ready for that he's overextended
so watch what i do take d4
now the first thing a lot of people will
see is wait a second he takes the knight
and he wins a piece because if i take
the knight he takes the bishop
what did he miss what do we do
1500 is fine that's when i started
playing the king's indian
i wouldn't say it's good for total
beginners though
i would recommend starting with a
queen's gamut very nice
ef6 and we are in good shape
uh and
let's see now what's going on here we
are attacking two
two pieces simultaneously in addition we
have opened an avenue to his king
that is a very dangerous avenue
okay and uh he is in huge trouble we are
also going to be up upon because we have
taken two pawns and he's
taken zero so we're going to be up a
piece
we're going to be attacking him uh sorry
we're going to be up a pond we're going
to be attacking him and he's
underdeveloped we are crushing him in
eight moves
this is why the king's indian is a great
opening
he's making it look good and we actually
get to keep the king's indian bishop so
we can take with either piece
uh the reason i don't really want to
take with the queen is maybe because he
has knight t5 attacking the queen
so let's take with the bishop again
keeping the queen for the more important
tasks
i have two headphones what do we do here
uh how do we continue and i've already
mentioned the move we just have to put
things in the right order
oh look at this little juicy morsel
right here we're going to attack the
hell out of that one
exactly he has to play bishop d3 to
defend and then how are we going to
follow up the attack
on the knight on e4 what are we going to
do to keep the attack on that going okay
all right uh sorry guys he gives up
that entirely okay now how do we convert
such a position in the easiest manner a
lot of people
want to take the pawn i'm sure no
no no no no there's a higher priority
the priority
is to stop him from castling if we can
stop him from castling we are going to
massacre him down the e-file
how do we stop him from castling now we
can give a queen check that's a great
move
but let's do that in a slightly subtler
way let's play queen e7
this is the way that i like stopping him
from castling because it also builds the
pressure on the e5 we kill two birds
with one stone
do you guys see how often i try to do
that when i have an intention that i'm
trying to fulfill with the move i'm
trying to fulfill other intentions along
the way
with that same move so if i'm trying to
stop him from castling i'm trying to
find a move that also
is somehow conducive to my to my uh
other goals okay bishop f5 is possible
but we can attack the queen war directly
we can also play rookie iii
uh the queen must move and after the
queen moves guess what
that pressure down the e file is finally
going to bear fruit
because we will be able to play what
move do not forget about pawns
as attackers people always forget about
pawns that and the fact that they can be
full-fledged participants in an attack
bingo goodbye bishop he can't castle he
can't well you can castle but now it's
too late he loses the bishop
miguel now he castles and the game is
over he loses two pieces
uh but remember what i kind of started
the speedrun with
what do you never forget to do when
you're up a lot of pieces
what do you have to remember and remind
yourself to do
and this is the reason a lot of people
lose winning positions
yep very good develop we we haven't
developed our queen side yet so let's do
that
the win is going to be a lot easier if
we have all of our pieces involved
and i like that people are whoa thank
you for that
okay now we can even avoid developing
but i will not i will
complete the development and uh the game
is over now this is what the king's
indian can get
can give you i mean a lot of extra
pieces we take another rook
and now we take a knight okay we're up a
couple of pieces here
and now it's checkmate that was a pretty
smooth king's indian game man
this reminds me of why i play it
i wonder what our accuracy was our
accuracy was probably perfect in this
game because
all of our moves were relatively
straightforward
um no but again let's not forget that
these people are
you know they don't necessarily sign up
to play me so
uh you know we have a good time but at
the end of the day i respect
i respect all these people greatly for
for playing me and you know
being good sports about it which they
are and their ratings are refunded
so again i'm laughing but it's all in
good fun i'm not trying to to make fun
of anybody uh
you know these guys are capable of
playing very very well and giving me a
run for for my money
okay um so quickly let's go over this
game because it wasn't that complicated
now a little bit of chess history when
when was the first time the king's
indian was ever played
the first time that the king's indian
was ever played according to my research
according to my records is 1850 it was
played by an
early indian master named but banerjee
and banerjee basically okay so this is
super interesting guys because this
tells you a lot about chess history
and the way that people thought 150
years ago so watch listen to this
so the indian master mohi sunder
banerjee
uh played a match against one of the
strongest
british players of the 1850s his name
was john cochran
john cochran was the most classic 19th
century player you could possibly think
of he did
everything by the book and he actually
developed the cochrane
gambit which is this move in the petra
by the way this is a very interesting
line i highly recommend it to
uh players in the 16 1700 range it's
actually not bad
uh and it can be used to get a very
interesting position in the petrov
so let's put on our 1800
hats let's imagine that we um
that we are uh i don't know let's
imagine that we're john cochran
i wish i had a book from the 1800s to
show you guys but i don't
uh and okay we just purchased my oldest
book is this one and we just purchased
this book
yeah so we're going to the board however
they talk their hand
our opponent in this game plays the
king's indian what is this opening
he's giving up all of the center what
does cochrane play in all of the games
in this match
knowing what you guys know about how
people thought back then what do you
think he did
what would what would somebody in the
1800s do here knowing the chess
principles that he knew back then
excellent man you guys are sharp this is
like the
well e5 no but he would calculate these
people knew how to calculate
he played the four pawns attack of
course because they were taught to
control the center
and i'm pretty sure that cochrane was
probably laughing at this opening
because what the hell is black doing
giving up such a monster center the four
pawns attack to this day
is a pretty dangerous opening
now shall we check something interesting
so i don't click paid people into
thinking this was a chess history stream
this han booked a socks bills modern
chess openings written in the early
1900s
shall we check what they thought of the
king's indian let's check what they
thought of the king's indian i don't
even know if it's analyzed
but let's see what they thought of the
king's indian 120 years ago
man this book is falling apart we might
need a german speaker but i do know the
german piece abbreviations
let's have a look now i'm going to the
table of contents
okay so this is italian
schweizer e4 e4 i don't want e4 this is
all e4
e4 this might this might just be volume
1 with e4
sadly this is i think this is just d4
defrosher this is the french no d4
wow e4 takes up this much and d4 takes
up this much
this is really cool because they didn't
take d4 seriously thank you danny devito
for this up
okay so we have d4 queen's gambits
king's indian probably has like a page
dedicated to it
this was only played a handful of times
at that time
okay d4 just bear with me please for a
moment
i'm trying to read this knight f6 knight
f3 d6 bishop f4 knight bd7 okay so we're
getting there
one e3 one c4 rare moves yes i have it
d4 f5 they analyze the dutch
wow look at this
you can see the mistakes being made in
the book in the dutch
they give the duchess an interesting
opening and in the dutch
they give this line which is a line
and then h6 is given an exclamation mark
this is a mistake this is a mistake
bishop h4 and now g5
which is a mistake and now they give
bishop g3
but white has a much better move in this
position
what is white's move and this move i
believe refutes the line e4
boom e4 now by the way they saw this
idea because they didn't give f4 here
because e3
undermines the pawn they didn't miss
this idea but they missed d4 in this
position
d4 is very strong and if you take then
you get checkmated and black gets
overextended here
so basically there are mistakes
so let's see martial election
d4d5 i'm still seeing d4 d5
yeah d4 spring at f6
so knight f6 was such a rare move that
they basically consign it into like
non-existent okay footnote number two
m85 okay black probably transposes
schlechter played this i don't care
which left we played one g6 one b6
white plays e4 come on guys you didn't
analyze the king's indian
step up your game i think we should
write these people whoever wrote this
book i know they're all dead now
but this is ridiculous no they didn't
analyze it
the king's indian is literally not
analyzed
it's just the dutch and then like rare
openings no it is kind of analyzed
wow they analyzed some interesting stuff
actually
marshall pillsbury yeah basically
relegated to
the king's indian is relegated to a
footnote
because in the year that this game was
played
the king's indian had only been played
and there's the reason why
now here's the reason no no no no this
book was published in 1918
over 100 years ago and at the time that
this game was published
the king's indian had been played
only excluding banerjee
excluding the indian master who played
it against cochrane
and that match might not have been
published or might not have been known
to these guys
excluding that game at the time that
this game was that this book was written
guess how many times the king's indian
had been played i'm counting right now
guess how many times the king's indian
had been played at the time this book
was written
six it was played six times before 1922.
and then the last time was 1912 18 it
was one time in 1879
1880 1880 1883
tarash played it in 1885. how forward
thinking was that guy
can you guys imagine and this is what i
tell everybody who disrespects the
classics and as stein it's you know
capital blank attarash they all kind of
sucked
guess what imagine being the first
freaking person
to play the king's indian the first
person to realize that you could give up
the
entire center the entire center
when everybody was laughing in your face
these
this is why i i really respect the
classics because we stand on the
shoulders of giants we know all this
stuff but imagine walking into a room
or a playing hall and playing something
and everybody's looking over your
shoulder who is this idiot playing this
stuff
so that's why the classics are great
because
somebody had the guts to walk into a
playing hall and be the first person to
play the king's india
okay and they did it without computers
and we got jayru gifting a sub as well
to
ziffer sorry i get worked up about this
because i'm really into history
but that's why this is so interesting
and imagine the effort that it took
to write a 780 page book in 1918 on
chess openings
i mean the guy who wrote this is a
frickin rock star
imagine how grateful people were to buy
this stuff and imagine
how much of an edge it would give people
to read it
and then there's the eight queen problem
there's a lot of stuff here there's not
just openings
i mean i wish i could speak german
there's like some chess studies and
stuff
um there's there's just a lot this is
just like jam-packed with cool stuff
games
ooh somebody made it somebody made a
note with a pen
wow somebody made a note here with a pen
this could have been written a hundred
years ago somebody somebody pointed out
a different move
in the margins with a pen
oh and this book belonged to frank roy's
md so this book is inscribed to a
medical doctor
who is a famous surgeon died i think 15
years ago from portland
and i got this from the mechanics
institute in san francisco
uh from my mentor john donaldson 1873.
so this was written originally in 1873
this is the second edition published in
1916.
but this was originally written 150
years ago
wow this is so cool there's like
notes here in pencil
and these notes are in german
wow so this this these were notes by
whoever owned this before this guy
uh what did the notes say no nothing
it's just like moves
it's just like moves uh but
well anyways i i have more of this stuff
i'll just need to find it
but basically that's that's that sorry
to go in the rabbit hole but this is
really cool i think
let me file this away this is the oldest
thing i have thank you uh
slant and shunt how much does that book
cost i don't think it says
but it's a beautiful it's a beautiful
book it's falling apart but look at the
effort that was put into the cover
handbook of openings
and then there's uh there's table of
contents and then there's a symbols
oh and look at these people they
actually have
uh question marks and castle long so
even in the 1870s
they were using algebraic notation
uh so you know people haven't really
changed you can see someone just reading
this
casually 100 years ago okay um
the second oldest thing i have is before
the time of beth harmon
and i've already showed this this is a
bound copy of the 1946
chess review this is
chess review was the monthly magazine
of the us chess federation and i have
the 1946 bound copy
there's some really cool photos in here
this for example is arturo pomar a
spanish
kid who would later go on to become a
grandmaster
i always look like looking at the prices
and stuff as i mentioned and some of the
articles
an invitation to chess by irving chernov
and kenneth harkness it cost
it cost two dollars two dollars
to buy a hard copy book
sportsman for tone tempo there's
grooming essentials
dr alexander alakine wow this is so
interesting
soviet union there's chess news
four famous books cost 250 that's
awesome
yeah i know that's like in in that money
it's it's a lot more but it's just funny
pawn snatch refuted chess marches on
alakine on the cover died this is the
this is the the magazine those came out
after alekhine died
in 1946. he was on the cover of the next
chess review article
don't forget to get a good night of rest
oh never never a grandmaster house
if you can't sleep try this
interesting let your jaws relax
wow so alakine had died
on march 24th a radio news flash
announced the death of world champion
alexander alekhine at the age of 53 in
lisbon
first reports described his death to a
heart ailment but a subsequent autopsy
disclosed that death had been caused
by asphyxia due to an obstruction in his
breathing channels due to a piece of
meat
yeah so that's the that's the prevailing
theory about his death is that he was
already in bad
health this was amplified by an
associated press dispatch
yeah there there's a photo of him when
alakine was found dead on sunday in the
hotel esteril
he held a piece of beef steak in his
right hand
intimates said friends said alekhine was
accustomed to eating with his hands
never using knives or forks when he
could avoid them
and that he would eat alone when he
wanted complete enjoyment from a meal
at the time of his death alekhine was
working on his memoirs and playing
training games with a francisco weapon
now this doesn't tell the whole story
because edward winter one of the leading
chess historians
believes that uh alekhine
well alekan was already in bad health he
was basically broke
a very tragic story but he was basically
broke
uh and he was in he was in poor health
so
basically the the actual story is is
more complicated
uh but anyways this is just interesting
okay
uh so let's do one more round of the
speed run and then i have commentary
indeed with robert at 9 00 a.m tomorrow
so
i do want to get a good night of sleep
okay uh let's do one more round of the
speed and we have over a thousand people
so
a big shout out to everybody watching
and a huge thank you to everybody who
was a participant in the earlier epic
stream uh i still
haven't fully recovered from that um
okay but um back then like you didn't
he was living in the hotel like he was i
think back then
like the meaning of a hotel was kind of
different 50 years ago in hastings
i have like more stuff chess ratings oh
postal chest ratings i think only
correspondence chess ratings existed
back then
um over-the-board chess ratings did not
okay let's continue
let's continue are you guys ready now
that we have
all this chess history in front of us
let's honor the greats
with one more solid round of the speed
run as we got kolarn with a
tier one sub keeps it going on the path
to 4 000 i can't believe i'm saying this
but we are over 3 000 subs i'm using my
earliest chess notebook to collect
people's questions
we've got present past and future with
us right now hopefully the future
generation of chess players in the chat
let's continue
danny k okay we have been playing the
accelerated dragon which i think people
are getting behind oh j
root 1500 bits
thanks man with a monster bomb right
there thanks man
okay uh so as people already know
this move bishop c4 is not effective
against the sicilian for what reason
what is the move and if you know the
move then by definition you know kind of
the reason that this move is good you
can play e6 but
the reason is not that we can play d5
the reason is that e6 blunts the bishop
and we don't even have to rush with them
i mean we'll play d5 but we don't have
to rush for the move with the move d5 we
can also develop our knight
uh which we will do now so we are just
the reason i'm playing fast is because
i'm i'm simply developing my pieces this
check is useless because i would have
developed it anyway
and now the queen could be in the
crosshairs of what what should we do
here
how do we at least try to punish him for
this
untoward and sort of slightly awkward
move we can play rookie and we
immediately create the pinning potential
he has to which he does
castles now the first thing we would
check uh for in this position is a
discovery
and bishop d6 comes to mind i'm sure
some people are thinking this
but uh remember that when you discover a
piece you can move the piece and defend
the other piece
so if bishop d6 the queen can come out
to d2
and simultaneously protect the bishop so
there's no point in making this
discovery let's save it for a rainy day
now when i say save it for a rainy day i
mean let's instead complete our
development
now again remember to apply the key
principle when you're developing your
pieces do not
obstruct the stuff that you want to keep
so where should we put this bishop let's
put it on f5
let's put it on f5 and let's see what he
does maybe bishop d6 will become good
again
for example if he plays knight bd2 i
don't think he will but if he plays
knight bd2
for whatever reason uh bishop d6 will
win a piece he goes queen d2 he gets
afraid of the
discovery now okay the nereditsky
approach here
is to identify what do i have against
sunny day who
you're still phoning robert man if only
i was commentating with him tomorrow
so the the neredinsky approach is to see
that the pawn on h3
is what i is what's called a hook and a
hook
is a pawn that is outside of its normal
position near a king that can be used
either as a
lever to sacrifice on or for other pawns
to advance and then to use that pawn to
weaken the king position so let's go
queen d7
and just sack on h3 opening up his king
position our queen will be in the attack
it's a very typical idea
in all sorts of positions particularly
in ones where you've completed your
development
and the reason the sacrifice is not that
risky is because we get two pawns for
the piece
so even if the attack backfires we will
have a significant amount of material
for the piece now is this
sacrifice sound i don't think so i don't
think it is particularly sound but i
don't think it's bad because
we're attacking his knight his queen is
super awkward he would love to play
knight bd2 here
developing his knight and defending the
knight on f3 but uh sadly he cannot
and uh we also have this g4 square
available for the queen should the
occasion arise
speedchest championship tomorrow all
right so queen d1
now how do we increase the pressure and
the heat
on the king side how do we add some
tabasco sauce to the attack
how do we add some tabasco sauce yeah
let's add some tabasco sauce
let's add some tabasco sauce now be
careful about the idea of knight e4
because remember that his bishop also
controls h2
his bishop also controls h2 so it's not
that simple
uh and in fact i would take on d5 if i
were white just fearlessly but people
just don't play like this
i guess he proved me wrong normally but
um
we have some really cool ideas here
actually
we have some really cool ideas here so
what can we do in this
in this position how can we play
so bishop h4 uh would be a great idea
if it weren't for well the presence of
the knight on f3
if it weren't for the presence of the
knight on f3
then we would be able to go bishop h4
and bishop takes f2
so how can we how can we
pave the way for the bishop to come to
h4
can we distract this knight from f3 yeah
we can we can we can go knight t4 now
this is again this is on sound he can
refute this and win
uh if he plays very accurately so i'm
banking on the fact that he doesn't play
accurately
uh because he's 1573 but i would not do
this against
a gm for example i'm just trying to show
how attacking works and often in blitz
you can get away with stuff like this
so let's see how he reacts to this now
we're trying to distract this knight so
that we can put a bishop on h4 and
threaten checkmate on f2
when you're attacking you want to make
sure that not only are you bringing
pieces into the game
but you're doing it in a very targeted
way you want to do it in a way that
such that the pieces actually accomplish
something you go c3 he doesn't take the
knight
so if we take his knight he takes with
the queen we certainly don't want that
we don't want the queen trade
um but this knight from
d4 can actually go somewhere kind of
nice
where can this knight from d4 go so that
it's still kind of relevant in the
attack
go to f5 uh and on f5 it potentially can
go to h4
and again distract the knight from f3
should the occasion arise
and queen g2 checkmate will be
threatened so we're sort of staying
on idle idol isn't we're idling the
engine here
and we're actually threatening knight h4
because he takes on h4 we will
kill two birds with one stone we will
move the bishop in
and that bishop will threaten checkmate
on f2 so let's see
how he chooses to defend against that
you guys can begin to appreciate here
how difficult it is to defend against
the style of play
even if an attack is unsound from an
engine's perspective for a human being
to defend against all this stuff is
incredibly difficult
uh is incredibly difficult i know that
express i don't like that expression
either
but he's doing it incredibly well so
knight to e5
uh okay so how should we proceed
how should we proceed should we take the
knight
so we if we go bishop h4 he he can take
on
on g4 ah this is very nice
we can actually go bishop h4 i think
this actually takes some calculation
from me but we can actually go bishop h4
so here's the calculation is not that
difficult
um because we are threatening checkmate
he can take our knight with two
different pieces he can
take it with the queen or he can take it
with
a knight if he takes it with the queen
then as i've explained many times he
should always check for the undefended
pieces the rook only one loses its
support so we actually do take the queen
then we take on e1 we win the rook that
same rook pins his knight to his rook
so even though he has two pieces for a
rook we have some compensation
the second way that he can take is with
a knight but then his queen is
overloaded
it guards both g4 and e1 so we can take
on e1 and then take on g4
this is the third move but this doesn't
do much we just move the king away
and the problem is renewed the king is
perfectly safe he decides on
this move so now we will win the rook
back he does get rid of the attack
but in return uh the attack in a certain
sense continues let's bring our other
piece into the game rook to f8
attacking the bishop so
this is again a very combative game our
opponent played extremely well he
defended extremely well but he's still
far from out of the woods because this
rook anyone look how it's paralyzing his
entire position
and that this i believe was a mistake
well actually not but again
we can well we can test him a little bit
let's test him a little bit
yeah 97 is the move that i had in mind
uh attacking both bishops at the same
time
if he moves his bishop to d2 which would
be i believe the right move
then we can actually win back the two
pieces for a rook we can play rook takes
b1
and then take the other bishop with our
knight he finds instead the move bishop
to d6
okay so he's pinning our knight to our
rook if we take his bishop he takes a
rook
so let's move the rook away from the pen
uh simultaneously trying to transfer the
rook to g5
and attack the knight on g4 and pinning
the knight
so let's see what he ends up
doing in this position see what he ends
up doing in this position
okay uh he's taking a little bit too
much time and if you're actually trying
to improve at blitz
you can notice that the style of play
makes it very difficult for people
to come up with moves fast and so in a
certain sense it's
favorable to play like this because uh
because
by definition you're you're you're
sucking the time off of your opponent's
clock
now what can we do here let's go rook g5
yes the move is king and now what do we
do after he moves his king
recognizing that the rook is pending the
night what do we do
i lived there freshman year or sorry
sophomore year
how do we enhance the attack on the
night we got booked
and we take the night and we are in very
good shape we are up in exchange
so this was only 26 moves which is kind
of interesting because it looked much
longer there was a lot of
interesting moments how could he have
refuted
this attack so the key moment occurred
in i think this position had he taken
the knight on d4 we would have played
bishop to h4 threatening checkmate on f2
and in this position i believe he could
have played the move bishop to g2
the purpose of this move is to attack
the queen and to open up the f1 square
for his king
we can still take on f2 but he shifts
his king to f1 there's a lot going on
here
but basically this boils down to two
simple facts
fact one is that white is up two pieces
so white can give away
something and he can still be up
material fact
two is that black's queen is hanging so
if i take on e1 he takes with his queen
we have a situation where both queens
are hanging
in such situations as i've explained you
want to look for desperado sacrifices
giving up your queen for the maximum
we can do that with queen takes g2 the
problem as i've explained goes back to
fact one white is up two pieces
white is no longer up two pieces but he
is still up one
and i have some pawns for it but by and
large it's an end game so white is much
better
okay so again this is one of those
things that looks super complicated but
it's not that hard to calculate
and people shouldn't be afraid of this
kind of chaos because you really want to
zero in on the observations that that
make a position tick you want to kind of
really figure out what's going on and uh
you shouldn't
you shouldn't be afraid just because of
the way that a position that a position
looks
okay all right great
so let's do maybe one more game
um one second please so if you played
accurately he would have been better yes
that's what i'm saying but i warned you
guys that's why
i believe the sacrifice was unsound and
if i was playing a gm
i would have probably played p5 to try
to drive his bishop in with c4
that would have been a good you know
that would have been a solid move just
to improve the position
you could have also dropped the bishop
away to fa you'll see this idea very
often in gm games
opening up the open file for for the
rook could have also gone
well h6 might allow the reciprocal
sacrifice on the other side
a lot of you said fifa can you play
cochrane gabby yes the next time our
opponent plays the petrov
i will play play the cochrane game but
i'm ready to destroy a 1600 this time
who plays the scandinavian
okay now in the scandinavian we know
already that knight c3
is the best move to attack the queen and
develop a knight
now we occupy the center with d4
and now we follow the ancient wisdom
of petrov who said to develop the knight
uh
to f3 first i don't think we played this
guy actually
i disagree now he's just moving his
pawns and there is no particular way in
which we should respond
no no we did not play this guy the last
time uh there is no particular way that
we should respond to this other than to
continue development uh
are you sure we played him well i'm
looking at my game history i don't see
him but anyways
bishop d3 is simple
oh it's just the overlay hasn't changed
there we go
the over that's so weird it contained
the name of the last opponent but
the moves are transmitted transmitting
correctly
okay so let's centralize the knight
that was really funny and develop our
bishop so right now i'm just developing
all my pieces i'm not doing anything
crazy
which is why i'm moving fast
okay now what should we do in this yeah
i was like what
what should we do in this position let's
bring our queen out to f3 which is a
very typical way to apply pressure on
his position
notice that i'm also giving up the d4
pawn and
there is a reason that i'm doing that
and the reason that i'm doing that is
because he's so poorly developed
if he takes on d4 with his queen his
queen is going to be incredibly
vulnerable to attack
now what should we do in this position
we can win a pawn
it's the rye lopez demon it's ray lopez
loose pieces drop off
boom if he takes we take the bishop
loose pieces drop off that's a free pawn
there's no reason not to take it
okay he goes knight d5 so he attacks the
bishop let's take it
now we do need to move the knight away
so let's move it back to c3
okay so we're up pawn we're in good
shape he's probably gonna go here
nope he's gonna go f6 okay now what
should we do in this
situation and i'll give you guys a hint
we can create a counter threat against
his pawn on h7 because we have a bishop
on t3 that's very very
strong a lot of people might think the
move is queen h5
but be very very careful because if we
oh we got another oh my goodness
oh my lance
got another one from gem jam another 10
000 are you kidding me
i will have a good night we're gonna go
queen h3
so that g6 doesn't come with tempo
what a day this has been in culminating
in
two bombs dropped by gem jim now we're
going to move our knight away now that
we've provoked the weaknesses in his
king side
and king h8 pin what does this tell us
about what we should do thank you so
much
what should we do here
boom if he will take his opponent on g6
yes
and the game is almost over that is the
second and again we do the same thing we
did earlier we just take a pawn and we
drop the bishop back
okay now we have a really nice tactic
how do i see this tactic what i'm seeing
is that the queen defends the pawn on h7
against checkmate
we know that when the queen defends a
pawn that's not a good situation we can
take a third pawn
and if he takes the queen oh sorry if he
takes the knight we can take on h7
and the game will be boy and lodge the
game will be over
now he's gonna go knight 97. now most
people here would take the rook
the thing about this is we can do a lot
more than take the rook we can do a lot
better because we have this h file open
we can attack
down that h file following the ancient
wisdom of the greats with knight takes
h7 we don't need to take bishop takes h7
because if bishop h7 we give up the
knight and that same knight can be used
to go to h7
himself and
this is just going to be
completely winning we are up four pawns
and we are crushing him with an attack
okay now let's find the checkmate
he has also given up his rook but there
is mate in two moves
how do we find the checkmate we realize
that we can move the knight away with a
discover check
our second mission in this position is
to cover the g8 square because after we
move the knight that is going to be his
only escape square
for the king and that's how you often
when you're discovering a check and you
want to checkmate your opponent's king
the way that you want to think about the
discovers can i move my piece away
such that that very same piece somehow
contributes the mating mechanism
as you guys can see the move is knight
f6 check
the game is over it's mate very simple
game we just developed our pieces
and this is why i don't recommend
opening such as this candy
to a lot of players in the intermediate
range because
they tend to do stuff like this giving
us a huge lead in development
the one thing i'd like to talk about is
what would have happened if we had
if he had gone queen takes d4 now
when you look at this move the immediate
thing you should notice is the
relationship between the queens so if
this bishop could move away with
check then that would win the queen so
you need to find a tactic in order to
force the king onto a square
where you could deliver check to this
looks like a complicated combination but
the logic behind it
no pun intended is very simple you're
just trying to get the king onto a
square
or you can deliver the discovery check
so he couldn't do this
and that meant he had to allow us to
continue putting our pieces on very good
squares
now we play knight takes p5 using the
fact that the bishop is unprotected
we drop the knight back we attack h7 if
he had taken the knight
we take it check and checkmate is very
simple we can even checkmate with the
pawn d takes c5
and um after knight g4 i mean his
position has already been softened up
we take on g6 we take on f6 distracting
the queen notice how our own queen and
i've mentioned this often the queen is
often sort of the supporting actress
a queen defends on g2 and simultaneously
is responsible for uh
basically he's the agent of of checkmate
what if he took the pawn later that's a
good question so if he took the pawn
here
we would have just defended the knight
and then brought the other look how
amazing white's position is
uh even upon down so basically this is
just completely overwhelming because
white's got pieces on amazing squares
and you can slide the queen over to h3
and create threats against the h7 pawn
so if he goes h6 you can already give a
discovery and win the queen
uh what if yeah so there's there's a
bunch of tactical details here but the
long and
short of it is that white's got a huge
attack
and the rest was very straightforward
now just moving knight back to f6
and covering g8 we could have also taken
the rook of course with total
devastation but we decided to play a
little bit more
precisely